Traduttore: Maurizio Berti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Mi hanno invitato qui a parlare.
Però, visto che ci siamo,
mi sembrava gentile onorare
le tavole di questo palcoscenico.
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Innanzitutto volevo tranquillizzare
la mia compagna Vanna,
che è qui tra voi,
perché sono tre giorni
che mi sente girare per casa
parlando da solo.
Volevo tranquillizzarla,
nel senso che è tutto ok.
Siccome parlare mi viene
un po' più complicato che suonare,
ho dovuto fare un po' di prove in casa.
Quindi è tutto a posto.
Cosa succede a un ragazzo di 14 anni,
che nasce e cresce ad Ascoli Piceno,
quando si accorge
che una delle sue passioni
ha preso il sopravvento?
E quindi non si può far altro che seguire,
cercare di seguire
a qualunque costo questa strada.
E spesso ci si può fermare
alle prime difficoltà,
e quindi si rimane
in un territorio circoscritto,
ci si fa il bagno nel laghetto sotto casa,
e questo per un milione di ragioni,
semplicemente perché è più semplice,
e si evitano critiche e conflitti.
Invece quello che voleva fare
questo ragazzo di 14 anni - cioè io -
era cercare di trasformare la musica,
cioè la propria aspirazione,
in qualcosa di più concreto,
qualcosa di più grande.
E per farlo mi rendevo conto
che siccome si trattava di una zona,
diciamo, non molto convenzionale,
dovevo fare questo
attraversando dei confini,
cioè varcando proprio dei confini,
e invece che fare il bagno
nel laghetto, tuffarsi nell'oceano
con la precarietà
di un camaleonte che fa surf.
Da lì il titolo di questo mio intervento
che è: "Come un camaleonte,
verso l'infinito e oltre..."
Il titolo l'ho preso componendo,
cioè prendendo delle citazioni
di due film che mi hanno
particolarmente colpito.
Il primo è il camaleonte
di Zelig, di Woody Allen,
il personaggio che si adatta
a qualsiasi cosa.
Mentre "Verso l'infinito, e oltre..."
è la voce registrata del robot,
cioè di Buzz Lightyears,
del film "Toy Story",
che ama dire questo slogan super positivo
pur rimanendo sempre nella stessa stanza.
Quindi la necessità qual era?
Di realizzare questo progetto.
E soprattutto, adesso vorrei rispondere
alla domanda che forse molti di voi
si stanno facendo in questo momento:
come può venire in mente,
a una persona che nasce ad Ascoli Piceno,
di diventare un bassista
super mega sensazionale,
come me?
La cosa più divertente è:
come trarre profitto facendo
qualcosa che ti piace così tanto?
Cioè come trovare qualcuno
che è disposto a pagare
per sentirti e vederti suonare
questo super mega ukulele,
come dicono i Minions?
È abbastanza complesso:
comunque partiamo,
in sintesi, dall'inizio.
Fin da piccolissimo,
per me la musica ha sempre
rappresentato un linguaggio spontaneo.
Come partiva una canzone
mi mettevo a ballare,
e quello è il primo sintomo.
Quindi se qualcuno ha figli
e succede questa cosa, è tutto a posto,
non è una cosa preoccupante.
Quindi ho iniziato a suonare il violino,
perché mio padre suonava il violino.
Quindi non c'era un motivo
di particolare passione:
però erano lì, i violini,
e quindi ho iniziato.
E da subito mi rendevo conto
che il violino non mi emozionava.
Nel senso che non avevo
questo desiderio pazzesco
di suonarlo tutti i giorni.
Però, studiandolo,
capivo che la prima cosa
che mi emozionava
era ascoltare una melodia,
e riprodurla in automatico.
Quindi sentivo una sigla alla televisione,
prendevo il violino e la rifacevo.
Adesso ve la faccio sentire con il basso,
vediamo se qualcuno di voi la riconosce.
[suona l'Almanacco del giorno dopo]
L'avete riconosciuta?
Eh., questa la generazione
del '70 se la ricorda.
Quindi mi divertivo
a fare questa cosa qua.
Invece quando dovevo
eseguire gli studi di violino
davanti all'insegnante,
forse per renderli meno noiosi,
li cambiavo.
E questo scatenava
le ira dell'insegnante,
ma proprio tipo:
"No! No! Non devi farla così!"
Però mi divertiva.
Però che dovevo fare?
Andavo avanti.
Cercavo di flirtare
anche con altri strumenti,
come il pianoforte,
che quando studi violino
lo fai complementare,
però non mi piaceva neanche quello.
Chitarristi? Ce n'erano troppi.
Veramente troppi,
come in Romagna negli anni 80,
tutti facevano i dj.
Quindi era, diciamo,
un settore un po' inflazionato:
e poi - questa cosa
sicuramente vi farà ridere,
infatti l'ho messa apposta -
non mi sono mai piaciuti
i capelli lunghi.
Lo sapevo.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Ho poi provato con la batteria:
ma era troppo faticosa da trasportare,
ed era un po' troppo nelle retro-file.
Poi alla fine il fato ha deciso per me:
il primo gruppo
di cui poi avrei fatto parte
aveva il bassista che era costretto
a partire per il servizio militare.
E non solo era partito,
ma aveva lasciato nella sala prove
il suo basso e il suo amplificatore.
Quindi come io amo dire,
e come dicono i piloti di aerei,
ho beccato lo slot,
sono arrivato e in una settimana
ho tirato giù tutto il repertorio
che loro stavano provando da mesi.
E lì lo studio del violino
è servito molto,
perché mi ha dato disciplina, rigore,
e ha sviluppato
il mio orecchio tantissimo.
Tutti e due, non solo uno.
Lì capisco che quel gruppo
sarebbe sempre rimasto una cover-band,
e quindi avevo bisogno d'altro:
dovevo varcare dei confini
e fare un'altra mutazione.
Qui ritorna il camaleonte surfista.
Mi piace questa figura
del camaleonte surfista
con gli occhi un po' così
che sta sul surf.
Però rimanevo sempre ad Ascoli,
e quindi cercavo di gravitare
in tutte le micro tendenze della città.
C'erano i jazzisti,
quindi arrivavo,
e mi mettevo a suonare così.
(Musica)
Loro adorano fare un sacco di smorfie,
però stanno fermi inchiodati.
E quindi frequentavo i funkettari,
quelli che sentivano il funky.
Quindi andavo da loro,
mettevo il basso un po' più giù,
e facevo:
e suonavo con loro.
Poi andavo da quelli
che facevano l'heavy metal,
e quindi cambiava l'impostazione:
molto aggressivo,
e il basso andava sempre più giù...
Grazie.
(Applausi)
Sempre molto arrabbiati erano,
sempre molto arrabbiati
e non se ne capiva la ragione,
cioè smettevano di suonare
- "Ciao come stai?",
addirittura con delle voci molto...
"Ciao come stai? Tutto bene?"
Così.
E poi è arrivato il gruppo punk,
e lì...
più giù di così
non si poteva andare...
Non era tanto una nota,
ma una sola frequenza di rumore,
però avevo preso
in considerazione anche quella.
Poi è arrivato il confine vero, l'oceano.
Ci si muove verso Milano.
Questa è stata la mia faccia
appena uscito dal treno
alla stazione di Milano la prima volta,
perché io non è che avessi
poi così viaggiato in famiglia.
Quindi arrivo a Milano e lì dico:
"Ok, questo è il Big data, l'Universo."
Però, come si faceva?
Mi serviva il passaporto ideologico.
Io lo chiamo così:
non è un passaporto
per andare al di là di un paese.
Era proprio ideologico,
dovevo capire la chiave d'accesso.
Così mi sono attaccato come un francobollo
a questa persona
che si chiama Robert Gligorov:
era molto inserito,
conosceva tutto
del mondo dello spettacolo.
Oggi magari mi sarei definito uno stalker.
Ero proprio fisso da lui.
Quindi il mio primo impiego musicale,
o forse strumentale al fatto poi
di essere accreditato come bassista,
era fare il tuttofare per lui.
Quindi davo da mangiare ai suoi gatti,
guidavo la sua macchina,
scaricavo i suoi bagagli,
scaricavo la spesa di sua moglie.
Però nel frattempo lui
mi presentava un sacco di persone.
Però non ero ancora proprio pronto,
cioè non c'era stata
quella mutazione finale
che mi aveva fatto capire:
ok, sei pronto.
Ma non ero così pronto
che Robert mi disse:
"Vieni con me a Parigi,
ti porto a vedere Sting
che registra un disco."
Io dico "Fantastico, Sting: ok, vado."
Guido fino a Parigi
- perché il deal era quello:
devi guidare la macchina fino a Parigi.
(Risate)
Arrivo a Parigi, incontro Sting,
Robert mi presenta:
"Lui è Saturnino
ed è un bassista, giovane."
Sting mi guarda, è gentile,
prende il suo basso,
me lo porge e mi dice:
"Questo è il mio primo basso."
Io lo guardo, prendo il basso,
non so cosa fare
(Risate)
e metto a posto il basso
sul cavalletto, guardando lui.
E che succede? Il basso cade.
(Risate)
Questo, sì, è un momento...
veramente... un highlight...
(Applausi)
Il basso cade
e succede che tutti
quelli presenti nella regia
si girano come per dire:
"Ma che ca....?"
E guardano me,
e io ho detto:
"Vedi? sono riuscito
ad attrarre l'attenzione su di me,
ma non è questo il verso giusto".
Non ero ancora pronto.
Poi invece succede che
tutte le cose che hai fatto
fino a quel momento
sembrano magicamente
lavorare all'unisono
per assisterti in quello
che stai per fare.
Mi trovo in uno studio
di registrazione a Milano,
dove poco tempo dopo
avrebbe registrato un album
molto importante per la sua carriera
L'album è "Una tribù che balla",
correva l'anno 1991.
L'artista per cui avevo registrato lì
si chiama Gatto Panceri,
ed è un autore molto conosciuto.
Il proprietario dello studio
mi ascolta, mi vede, mi conosce,
e quando Lorenzo chiede:
"Sto cercando dei giovani musicisti
per mettere su una band"
il proprietario dello studio,
Massimo Lepore,
che non finirò mai di ringraziare,
disse: "Il bassista ce l'ho io".
Mi chiamò, io arrivai subito in studio,
e incontrando Lorenzo capii
che il basso caduto di Sting,
il basso suonato così,
e tutto quello che era successo
- il violino, tutto - erano serviti,
e stavano vibrando
veramente all'unisono.
Poi più o meno
quello che è successo dopo
molti di voi se lo ricordano
e lo conoscono.
Però la sintesi
di tutte queste mutazioni
e tutte queste esperienze,
è arrivata 20 anni fa,
quando mi trovavo in studio
e finalmente mi sono reso conto dopo
di aver trovato la mia voce,
cioè era venuta fuori,
dallo strumento che imbracciavo,
una melodia che è riuscita
a far vibrare l'allineamento
dei pianeti nell'Universo.
Quella linea di basso fa così.
Tornando un po' indietro,
ricordate quando vi ho detto
che mi piaceva tirare giù e rifare
le melodie che arrivavano
dalla televisione?
Questa che avete ascoltato adesso
è la baseline su cui si è costruito
"L'ombelico del mondo",
che è un pezzo che io
considero la mia pensione.
(Risate)
Diciamo che siamo riusciti
nel primo progetto,
nella prima fase progettuale.
Però è rimasto
quell'aspetto camaleontico
che è riuscito a far mimetizzare
all'interno di questo pezzo
una sigla che io sentivo tutte le sere,
quando mi trovavo a cena con i miei,
e che mi ha trapanato il cervello,
che era la sigla delle previsioni
del tempo di Bernacca.
Infatti lo stacco dell'Ombelico
del Mondo, che ritmicamente fa così
io dovevo sottolinearlo
con il mio strumento
perché arrivava in un certo punto
e ci ho messo questo...
E non se ne è accorto nessuno.
(Applausi)
Concludo dicendo
che l'adattabilità del camaleonte
è, per quanto mi riguarda,
la forza della vita.
Quindi... andate,
come un camaleonte,
verso l'infinito e oltre.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)